how important is it for audiences to see
themselves
in the characters they see on screen
how important is it for audiences to see
themselves
i
i think they should see themselves in
whoever the protagonist is
but i think the thing that people
confuse is that that that uh person
should look like you
i there are so many times i've seen
movies where i identified with a
character who wasn't my age wasn't my
gender wasn't my ethnicity and i think
we live at a time now where
people are so narcissistic they look at
movies like video games
when
whereas in a video game you could
actually design for many games design a
character that looks like you
that looks almost exactly like you for
certain video games for movies
i think what people are talking about is
representation i think i do believe that
representation is something that is
important it's it's important to have
uh
you know
different types of people represented
within a story
where possible but if you are only
capable of identifying with a character
who looks mostly like you i would say
that you're a narcissist and i think
that you
you
would benefit greatly
from identifying with characters who
don't look like you and quite frankly i
tend to gravitate towards stories where
i mean look i spend all day with myself
i don't want a story about me
i'd like to see a story about a
character that takes me to a different
place
uh that is experiencing different
challenges in life that i may never have
faced
so that i can
safely experience that story through
through them
and
they don't have to look like me i think
that there's been an
put on that that there needs to be
characters that look just like you well
what are we gonna do
go through every single ethnicity gender
sexuality and remake all the stories
with characters
that fit every single checkbox
i think that just gets
exhausting
i think it gets exhausting and i i
really actually tend to gravitate
towards stories in particular world
cinema you know i grew up watching uh a
lot of asian cinema as a kid
and
i loved it it was an opportunity to
explore another culture you know um
you're gonna think this is crazy but i
saw a movie called godzilla's revenge
when i was a kid
and i uh godzilla is in the movie
and is a hero to a young boy
and he has these
fantasies in his head about godzilla and
befriending godzilla's son minya
and within that story with this little
child which is around the same age as me
but not the same ethnicity
he was japanese and
but it was interesting to see how he he
ate you know you know these different
experiences in the culture were very
different and i found that just
really fun i connected it with him
because he was my same age it really
mattered very little to me that i looked
like
the the kid in that movie so i think
you're missing a huge opportunity to
experience
the world differently
through someone else's eyes i think
that's the whole and i've said this
before it's the purpose of all fiction
comic books movies video games novels
to see the world through the eyes of
someone else
and and movies give us an opportunity to
do that and if you're
wholly obsessed with a character's gotta
be like you go play a video game design
a character that looks just like you and
go play that video game but you're
missing an opportunity
certainly when it comes to comes to
movies
is there a healthy aspect
of narcissism in cinema i mean imagine
you go through life never seeing
yourself
in a film or never seeing yourself in
magazines and then finally now
you're seeing people that look like you
that have gone through the same thing
yeah now here here's
here's a caveat to that i would say that
you know
it's
i think it is important to have
different types of people represented
but help me to identify with that person
with their plight their story their
challenges
their struggles
you know i think this
[Music]
it's it's a challenge i would lay out
there to independent filmmakers right
have an audience identify with a
character that
where the majority of people will
identify with someone who isn't them
tell their story i get involved in the
story and the challenges for that
character i don't necessarily tend to
focus so much on
on uh you know who the person is from
their you know
outward traits right i mean one of my
heroes growing up was the character
ripley from alien uh
that one is brought up quite a bit
sigourney weaver is so great i mean
even even in the
even in the episodes or the
the the sequels in
you know the alien movies that are not
that great
she's always great sigourney weaver
always seems to deliver
and you know i saw that when i was a kid
wasn't her age wasn't i you know
i
i was not a woman
and you know like i still identified
with her mainly because i thought she
was the smartest person
the other thing people forget about the
first alien movie
i mean there's a book about this save
the cat right she went back and saved
jonesy the cat
and i think that that that was one of
the things that and this happens late in
the movie right
so
obviously she has a relationship with
this cat jonesy
and identified with that because you
know what i have a cat
you know at the time i had a cat i
pretty much have always had cats so
or you know
it just i i think that that's an easy
way to identify
what is self-insert a self-insert in a
movie is when someone will literally
take themselves and just make them the
hero of the story
and
i i i find that to be kind of
off-putting
we we've seen it happen uh it happens
it's happening now with more frequency
where you see
you
you see a move and you're like okay well
that's interesting who that person is
and then when you find out the
backgrounds of the creators it tends to
just be almost exactly like them down to
even some physical attributes and i'll
say that many are guilty of this
if you look at the work of works of say
david cronenberg or even david lynch
mclaughlin is pretty much a self-insert
for for david lynch kind of wide-eyed
about the world and
if you compare their haircuts at the
time
they pretty much had the same hair same
thing with um
uh same same thing with uh david
kronenberg right
i mean
when you know he used uh
jeremy irons in was it dead ringers he
i mean it looks like david cronenberg
let's be honest right
um
so you see when filmmakers do this
sometimes i think they do it
subconsciously
uh but you're seeing i think it more and
more and it can be used to good effect
and um
you know i mean george lucas named the
lead character of his star wars saga
luke kind of after himself luke lucas
you know
uh that could be argued
so self-insert i think as long as you're
aware
can work i think when it's done almost
to an exacting point um
i i don't know that it that it succeeds
every time
what if we just own our narcissism and
say okay
i like to see myself on screen like that
well i think the very act of thinking
that someone would be interested in a
story that you thought up in your brain
is kind of narcissistic to begin with to
think well uh i have this idea in my
head i'm gonna make a film write a film
make a film produce a film direct to
film whatever part of the process you
exist in i'm gonna do that and then
you're gonna give me money to see this
story
uh yeah that i mean look you have to
have sort of a healthy level of
narcissism but i think that needs to be
balanced with
self-awareness i think it's
absolutely critical
that you have a profound
self-awareness
to be able to balance that narcissism
and just keep it so it's it's not the
thing that dominates i mean
one thing i would uh if i could throw
some couple tips out to writers one keep
a blazer in your car
wherever you go you never know where
you're gonna be where throwing on a
blazer
whether it's a casual one like i have
now or whatever you just throw it even
over a t-shirt um it immediately
sort of ups your game right
some level of upscale casual the other
thing is i never go anywhere without
carrying notebooks
right so i always have a tiny notebook
very tiny that fits in the back of my
pocket
and
i'll carry this notebook around and i'll
jot down ideas and it's better than yeah
i know we want to use the notes function
in your phone no this is better there's
something about sitting there with a pen
and i always carry a pen the space pen
the space pen is in my pocket currently
oh great okay but this goes in my back
pocket and then the problem is um i
believe leading a creative life where
there are financial concerns you have to
balance two things one is you know
obviously being able to be creative the
second thing is being successful uh from
a business standpoint and that's why you
need a notebook that's a little thicker
probably like this and
i hate to tell you this you're gonna
spend your creative time probably like
this and your business time in order to
succeed in the film industry a little
more like this notebook this is like a
a moleskin and i think
completely describes my sentiments for
dealing with that aspect of the industry
and where does um
everybody's narcissism fit into that so
they've got their blazer they've got the
two books the small one for creativity
the large one for business but then
we're all
narcissist in one way or another where
where how do we balance that
uh you you balance that with being
humble
so that you keep that narcissism in
check but be bold
right and and that comes with asking
questions it comes with uh
relating to people and not by text and
not by social media posts i mean
actually talking to people
and i and uh
especially when i meet young filmmakers
today they i just see that they haven't
learned all the lessons and they're
maybe out of balance
and the thing i see most often is just
relating to people one-on-one
face-to-face so
you know throw on a blazer or something
upscale casual that you feel comfortable
in
that represents you
and how you feel about yourself and and
and go out there and ask questions and
don't be afraid don't be afraid to say
hello don't be afraid to say hi
uh don't be afraid to say hi if you run
into me i'll probably say hi back
and and we may get no conversations
probably because you know if if you meet
me in person you even know who the heck
i am
um you know we probably are into the
same things
movies is a great place to connect with
anybody
because who who doesn't like movies why
why are you why are you watching me why
are you watching this channel
yeah i've had some great conversations
with total strangers after movies it's
great i know i've said this before but
it's it's movies are a way to have a
conversation about anything
anything in life
so be fearless about having those
conversations and keep your narcissism
in check i i'll say just like
when it comes to people i have met in
the industry people at the highest
levels
i'm talking about major
celebrities superstars
are the most humble people i've ever met
and then it's generally the people that
are sort of trying to claw their way to
the top that that you see are kind of
having that
that that struggle with their own ego
why do you love movies so much
i
feel like i love movies because it's
like it's like a waking dream right it's
it's a it's a dream and an experience
where
you can
you know
enter the mind of a character and
experience the world through their eyes
and it's it's actually safe
right whether that character
you know
um gets horribly injured
has uh
terrible things happen to them or loses
you know loved ones friends family
members
you're you're able to experience those
things the kinds of things that
everybody experiences in life in a way
that's safe
and in a way that imparts lessons
whether you're aware of it at the time
or not
there's something in our lizard brain
that responds to storytelling
because i i think it's
it's it's a way for us to exercise our
own demons or to deal with
loss and pain from our past
and that's why i think storytelling and
in particular movies
and in particular movies and seeing a
movie in a theater when it's dark and
you're focused and you're not on your
phone you're not distracted although i
will say there is an entire category of
movies that i would say this would be a
good movie to watch while you're folding
laundry
and i have watched those movies
and i have folded laundry while i've
watched them but the
um a film i know i'm really going to
care about i'm going to see in a theater
in the dark experience the world through
that character's eyes and
and
come out the other end better for it
and
it's so universal that feeling
that feeling that's why
you know
wherever you go in the world
um
people people love
to
you know
have us have a story unfold on the big
screen i think there's something primal
about that that goes back to telling
stories around the campfire or just a
fire
right there's there's something about it
that's just embedded in our heads and
that's why you know um the love and
passion for film is so universal
worldwide
and when did you find that category of
the uh folding laundry film
i i think the folding laundry film came
during the pandemic
in terms of
watching stuff i probably would not have
watched otherwise
when it's just well
we're here there's no movies at the
theater i'm gonna watch this thing and
so i think there is an entire category
of movies and a lot of uh i would say
series television where
you can get a lot of the story that is
happening just from the it's just from
hearing it so it's kind of an uh a radio
play
and they say that the original star trek
series if you're not watching it if
you're just listening to it and i can
confirm this because when i was a kid i
used to record the audio of old episodes
of star trek and listen to them and even
though i wasn't seeing everything when i
would listen to those cassette tapes
later
i still got
got the story
you know all of your narrative points
your
your character moments you know your
drama from the music
uh there there's a whole
world uh
of just like just that that you can
experience just from listening to it
and i i would i would recommend just um
as an exercise for fun
some of the content on streaming
services like netflix you can get not
just the captions on but there's a thing
called audio description
and i strongly recommend that you do
this try this out for fun take something
you like if audio description is an
option that's available it's for people
who are disabled uh may may not be able
to see
and not only do you hear the dialogue
you hear a description of a narrator
telling you what has is happening action
wise on the screen it's it's in a way
almost like having the screenplay read
to you it's
it's i mean it obviously has a function
a useful function for people who are
unable to see
but it also
as as a way of learning
you know you you can you can listen to
these heck you can listen to them while
you're driving and you get the entire
story the audio descriptive version um
there's even uh you can look this up
online there's there are people who list
some of the best audio descriptive
versions of content
so
i i find it really useful i think it's
interesting but the folding laundry yes
i think we've all had that experience
where you're like
uh
this thing that i'm about to watch
doesn't deserve all of my attention for
me it's generally romantic comedies i
romantic comedies
as much as i am sometimes forced to
watch them
i feel like that's
that's something i can multitask and
still enjoy
okay so suppose tonight is laundry night
so after this interview i'm gonna you
know go down to the laundromat and then
i'm gonna come back
and start folding and organizing can you
recommend two movies for me oh sure uh
i
marry me
with jennifer lopez which i saw recently
that's a totally uh a full laundry movie
and uh i would say death on the nile
for
recent films okay they may not be recent
when you're watching this i have no idea
when you're watching this when are you
watching this i don't know
all right great
i want to do laundry right now check
them out
but we all know we have those right
everyone where you're just like this is
like my full attention is going on this
christopher nolan movie or whatever it
is we're seeing like i you know
i'm gonna turn off the lights and i have
my little i have like this uh sort of
led like blue light that goes around my
television kind of kind of makes a movie
theater experience in 4k whatever but
then there's other things where you're
like now i'm just going to have this on
in the background or for me it's even a
movie i've seen so many times i can
quote the entire film
or what's great is when you think you're
going to watch a film like that and
you're actually surprised like i was
watching old episodes do you remember
vr5 no i don't remember oh okay so it
had lori singer and it was about her
um she had this gift of being able to go
into virtual reality and she was the
only one that had this ability and so
she was being like
wanted by big tech at that time which
was in the mid 90s and it the
storytelling was excellent you know it's
got cool old graphics and modems but
i thought oh this is the perfect thing
to put on and actually
i couldn't do anything else right right
like some of those you put on thinking
like ah whatever i'm gonna
you know i'm gonna i'm gonna organize my
receipts right okay that's something
here to do you put something on and then
you do get caught up i mean that's
that's a pleasant surprise but but i
kind of plan my viewing that way because
i tend to watch
at least a movie a day if not more
it's just part of what i do
what does an american film mean today
i really think that
there is no american cinema today the
last great era of american cinema was in
the 70s and probably the 80s as well
but um i think that the american
identity is so fractured because of
current day politics that there's almost
no such thing as a movie that everybody
can get behind
i think the most recent example of one
was
the latest spider-man movie spider-man
no way home which was a
an incredibly fun
like
spider-man not just a spider-man movie
it's a spider-man movie that was built
up over 20 years of spider-man movie
fandom starting with toby mcguire um
andrew garfield
you know and and building up to this
where now that all the spider-men are
are united that was like hey we can all
get behind this you know it's a
completely fun superhero movie ride
we can all get behind it is that an
american film
i don't know i would argue that the
superhero genre is something that's very
american made
but
i i really feel we've lost our identity
as a country because it's so fractured
into
multiple different americas
uh
and
i'll give you an example this is a weird
thing i did i did a panel
at a
convention called politicon and i
pitched a panel called trump the movie
and i had a friend of mine who was a
screenwriter i had a friend of mine who
worked in film development and i asked
like you know almost every president
post
their presidency has a movie made about
them right not a documentary a dramatic
movie that you know sort of goes through
the highlights the low lights and you
know
and and i wondered if if a trump movie
would ever be made
how would you market that movie
and i got it was a very interesting
discussion because we got into this
whole thing of like okay
you make the movie whatever the movie is
what kind of movie would it be would it
be more comedic would it be sort of
farcical
you know like maybe
maybe like from the mind of adam mckay
or something like that you know like
like what would it be one but then here
becomes the challenge of marketing that
movie which comes back to the question
of american cinema okay you've made a
movie about the trump presidency
who is it for and how do you market it
do you do a marketing campaign that is
for
the red states
that makes trump look like a hero
do you do another campaign
another marketing campaign from the same
movie
that talks about how he's a horrible
human being
and
this one these are the trailers you
would run in the blue states i think it
would be really interesting to see
and which is why i think a movie like
that will not be made
i don't think that there'll be a
dramatic
telling of his story
of of the trump presidency it's just not
going to happen and i think it has to do
with our fractured america that's why we
have no
really cohesive american cinema
i think that there are outside interests
and the concerns of our corporate
factory filmmaking
are that this movie needs to play
globally
so it that again and i've talked about
this many times the check boxes that
need to go you know in order for
something to play to the world
means that you've you've kind of
distilled it and and it's not really a
holy american
uh american movie and the only way you
would notice this is if you watched a
lot of foreign
foreign films
or or what they call now world cinema so
i would say to you
i i say as an exercise for yourself
watch a canadian movie
watch a canadian is very canadian and
you know the
a lot of countries actually subsidize
their
filmmakers and and the arts
and in particular is the canadian film
board that you pitch a movie to the
canadian film board has to have a
certain percentage of canadian talent in
it
large percentage it has to have canadian
themes and made for people in canada
and there are a lot of things
you know
if you're watching this you're american
you're not going to get the jokes
i grew up
uh in michigan
just outside of of canada
and uh and so i experience the cbc i
watch canadian children's programming
i watch canadian movies i watch canadian
hockey i became a hockey fan from
watching the cbc but it's really
interesting to see how distinct the
american identity is to the
canadian
canadian culture
so do yourself a favor and watch
see films from other countries and
you'll notice how important it is for
those countries to
to lay out their identity and their
culture in particular french cinema
does that as well um
so i'd say broaden your horizons broaden
your media diet and you'll just notice
that most of the movies that are made in
america now are not for america they're
for the globe
they just are and so
i think what's happened is it's eroded
our identity as americans or something
we could get behind because like i said
you're going to make a movie about trump
you're going to have two marketing
campaigns for that movie no matter what
that movie ends up being
well let's suppose we just take the name
trump out of it we could use any
president really in the last let's say
20 years we could use
any media figures in the last few years
if we were to have a trailer that was
specific to their audience wouldn't it
be almost considered propaganda
well i would say that
at least when it comes to
to documentaries it's almost all
propaganda now
i mean i i would say to documentary
filmmakers it's just like i i i see a
lot of docs
small indie docs um that come to film
threat for us to look at and it's almost
all solidly on one side of the equation
or the other i've seen
you know
pro-trump documentaries i've seen
anti-trump documentaries i would say
that the only one that was truly
unbiased was made by a british filmmaker
called the accidental president oh yes i
heard of that yeah and i strongly
recommend the accidental president it's
um
it's just one because it's made by a
brit is just like look
got no skin in the game
you know let's let's look at trump as a
person and and what he did and it's it's
it's really fascinating because i think
it's an it's an unbiased look at that at
his run for the presidency
but really most political documentaries
i see now they're either i i can already
tell it's like oh team red team blue
where where where what happened to being
unbiased what happened to being a
journalist and seeking out truth no
matter where it leads
you know that used to be the way things
were
not sure what happened to that um you
know and i've often said
film thread
mymediaoutlet filmthreat.com
where we review independent films we're
politically agnostic we have people on
all sides
um you know on all different uh
diversities of thought i think is my
more
what takes priority with me
um and i do enjoy reading someone whose
opinion doesn't completely line up with
mine it's an opportunity to to learn
something but i but i really see a
fracture in in the world of doc
filmmaking where most of what's being
produced is
purely propaganda
you know um there was a
a
and and to be clear my politics are very
middle of the road
you know sure i i can sit here and talk
to you all day about star wars
and star wars is actually a good place
i'm sure we'll get to some star wars
talk star wars a good place because it's
a thing that
most people have seen 99.9 of people
have seen it so it's a great entry point
to talk about lots of issues
um that particular movie or film series
and all that it begat um
but
but boy we we've really gotten to a
place now where i just
have concerns about we've lost the
ability to objectively look at facts
and
i think that's lazy
here's why it bothers me it's lazy
because
just as someone who's politically been
in the middle which means i
generally despise both sides
you know i think that
let's come up with solutions to problems
and if you're focused on the solution
really
well it shouldn't matter necessarily
your the politics or
what you may be compromised by when it
comes to your donors but i but um now i
feel that if you are on one side of the
other i feel that that in my opinion is
kind of lazy because
what what it says is the thinking is
done for you
which is why i think there are many ways
to look at an issue so
um i would just like to see documentary
filmmaker filmmaking become
um less less biased
i think i think that would be a great
service to all of us
is writing weaker today than it used to
be
i would say absolutely writing is weaker
today and and i i've looked at this and
and
i think the disappointment i have about
it is that one
we live in a time where media is so
accessible
in two clicks you can see anything
including movies that just opened in
theaters
right like whether it's available on a
streaming service or whether there are
other means
so much content
and i despise that word but i'll use it
so much is available to us
that what i fear is the current
generation of writers are not influenced
by life
they're not influenced by
uh great novels that they've read
they're not influenced by
classic films they're not influenced by
travel where they've traveled the world
they're not influenced by loves that
they've had great loves they've had or
loves they've lost they're not
influenced by
parenting experiences that they might
have had
or
experiences with family or experiences
real world real life experiences my
concern is that most movies being
written today movies and television are
written by
a generation that is influenced by other
movies so
there's this
snake eating its tail of writers
influenced by
other things they've seen rather than
life experiences when you look at the
very first star wars movie george lucas
i know i bring it up a lot
but star wars was influenced by many
things you know serials from the 1930s
from things like flash gordon and buck
rogers i mean george lucas famously just
wanted to make flash gordon but had
trouble with getting the rights it was
influenced by marvel comics
it was influenced by a tragic event
where he almost died
in a car accident and was in the
hospital for a long period of time
and that near-death experience
changed george lucas
much much of his influence was from also
his father
in his life who was a successful
business person who he looked up to
um a lot of his experience was growing
up in in modesto
people
uh you know the obsession over car
culture
and hot rods
when you see that in the character of
han solo
you know it's kind of a guy who's into
hot rods the millennium falcon is a hot
rod
but
so much of the influences that george
had both from life
and
so much uh classic literature and
storytelling were kind of thrown in a
blender and now you've got every star
wars movie is just influenced by the
last star wars movie
or the last star wars tv show
or what they call
this horrible term member berries
which is we're going to sort of throw
out these member berries remember that
remember that character remember this
character
remember that and what it does is it
takes it completely takes the mystery
half of the fun of some of these
characters from the star the world of
star wars is the fact that we didn't
know anything about them that we could
use our imagination so what's happening
is the uh what you're doing in it is
you've got this generation of writers
that are weaker because they're just
influenced by the previous work
right
and then secondarily you're taking
you're you're dumbing down the audience
and making them lazier
because
they're they're not able to even make up
something in their head about a
character that was once mysterious and
had two or three minutes of total screen
time in a film series
boba fett now you've expanded on him to
the point where okay we get it we know
everything about this character right
like
and and i find that disconcerting
um
you know i don't know i i i think that
there's something to be said um
from work that comes from older writers
who have had some life experience i can
always spot just because i've had kids
and raised kids who are now off on their
own and pay their own bills which is
awesome
but having been through that experience
i can always see
how false
a parenting relationship is when i see
whether it's
a filmmaker writer director who has
never had children
in their lives and i see and there's
like oh
a dad would never do that or no way
would a mother act that way towards a
child i just i kind of see that and i
think it just there's a falseness that
just comes from my personal experience
that now does it completely ruin the
movie not necessarily not necessarily
but i think that
writers would benefit from
having the time to experience much of
life
first
and then bringing that to
their writing
not in the way of like necessarily a
self-insert but at least being able to
what is it like to lose a loved one
and happen you know have it happen right
in front of you you know what i mean
that
that kind of experience
if you've ever been in the room where
someone close to you has passed away
um very difficult experience to go
through and um part of the therapy
dealing with that is through creativity
and writing
so
i do think that
our current generation of writers is
is weak because they haven't taken the
time to have those experiences
sure there's the age thing do you think
the internet plays a lot into that
because let's say gen xers we didn't
have access to that and maybe baby
boomers and beyond
that we couldn't just easily
go on rotten tomatoes or imdb and look
something up right and in some ways
that's wonderful but in some ways maybe
it's a disservice to creativity
so yeah i think access to too much
information can
uh
can hamper creativity you know when
you're bombarded by too much
i i think i think that that can hurt
i think going on a writing sabbatical is
good with no computer you know
um again bring your notebook they're
portable they go anywhere they never run
out of power
although your pen might run out of ink
um but you know
yeah i i do think that
life experience is incredibly important
and when you look at the stories of how
some
great works were written the stories
behind those
um whether it's a film or a novel or
whatnot
there's always more to the story
there's always more to the story of the
primary
creative person involved
what about the type of life
and the type of
experiences this person has had because
you know there could be some people that
they maybe had more of a sheltered
existence
so they're only going to have a certain
frame of reference for writing a story
whereas i've known some people that
they've gone to europe didn't tell their
family had just the clothes on their
back and learned to survive there for a
month somehow and came back unscathed
but that would that's a different life
experience than your parents driving you
to college and
getting you set up in your dorm room
well i i think
i think the reason
that um we live in such a bizarrely
divided time where people are fighting
over in my opinion some of the stupidest
arguments i've ever heard and i think
part of it is that we need struggle and
we need adversity
because i believe that
struggle when it comes to us as a human
self
is
and the way of overcoming a struggle
is
uh this is gonna sound strange is puzzle
solving
it's overcoming that is you know in a
video game it's leveling up right but i
think part of the struggle is okay um
here you know you're you're not making
ends meet with your bills you're gonna
keep having that problem until you do
something different
you know your relationship's not working
out well it's probably not the people
that you're dating it might be you and
the choices that you're making
solve that problem
and i i feel like
we live in a time where people are kind
of manufacturing problems to experience
adversity that they're really not able
to experience in their real lives which
explains to so much of the nonsense that
you see online with people battling each
other each other over things that are
uh pointless um i try to not get
involved in those kinds of discussions i
find them a waste of time and uh
you know time is limited
i want to focus on the things that
matter right
and
choose to use my time in a way that's
wise where i end up with a result i can
look back and go okay i sacrifice not
arguing with people on twitter six hours
a day but look what i was able to do
or
rather than writing thousand 500 word
thousand word facebook posts arguing how
right i am about a thing
i wrote a thousand words a day and in
two months i had enough
for a book enough material for a book
which is technically what you would have
if you wrote a thousand words a day for
two months you'd have enough material
for a book so i think that as humans
you know we we seek
out as a way to kind of level up or or
improve our situation we need that
because and this is why this is going to
sound like even more of a weird rabbit
hole you can go down and research this
even is puzzles are so popular
puzzles gaming video gaming you know
uh puzzle solving checkers chess i mean
look at the history of gaming through
humanity right there's a reason video
games
are more popular than movies
video games make more money than movies
and the fun of a video game is solving a
problem
and i think we need that we need that
our human
we need to
puzzle solve solve issues
we need we need adversity to fight
against to
level up i think it's it's your
self-awareness uh
you know
plays a lot into are you going to keep
going down that road and making that
same mistake
and spending all that time on social
media arguing with people you've never
met or maybe like divert that energy
into something more useful
so
that would be my advice
there but um
go down the rabbit hole of puzzles
through human history and you'll find
that it's something that um
that humans have kind of always had
around in addition i would i would
research
and look into how children learn
do children learn through memorization
they can yeah memorization is a great
technique for kids to learn
more effective is
turning things into games or puzzles
kids love it and they gravitate towards
it what if we're not designed to be
totally harmonious and what if groups
need a scapegoat because it makes them
closer so the group can bond if they
have an enemy
yeah um
that's a scary thought that you just
expressed and i and i and i see that um
when it comes to our current
climate
um
i i think that that's something as a
human species that we need to overcome
i think we have to overcome the
the inclination to do that to vilify
someone as a way to feel
superior as a way to
uh
other them
and vilify whatever it happens to be
about we must learn to resist that urge
to do that
um
and to have some empathy for someone who
may not think the way that you do
who who who may live a life that you
don't 100 percent approve of now if that
person isn't doing anything that hurts
anybody else i don't know why that that
would bother you
for some people it does and i think that
that we have not as a species reached
that point yet
um
i like to think that in the
uh gene roddenberry future that he
envisioned for star trek in the original
series and and next generation they talk
about having overcome those types of
things
and a more elevated existence were
certain types of things well as a human
race we got over that right well we
certainly haven't in our present day
and i hope that we learn too
why do popular franchises fail
i feel that popular franchises tend to
fail because
corporations are incapable of making
them under the current factory
filmmaking conditions
one popular franchises
are
created
generally by a singular person
who
was not paid by a company to think that
up that it was an idea that came
not necessarily fully formed but
percolated for years from that person's
experiences whether it's a gene
roddenberry with star trek whether it's
a george lucas with star wars whether
it's a j.r.r tolkien
with the lord of the rings series
a franchise comes birthed
from
a person not because a company hired
them to think up a new franchise it came
out of someone because it was a creative
thing that they needed to express
and
big companies which are required
to fully fund
a huge property or franchise
the conditions under which
content is made at those corporations
is not conducive to a singular creative
voice
it's
art by committee
there are other concerns budget is a
concern
is it going to have a happy meal
i mean um tim burton famously uh got in
trouble
after the uh sequel to his 1989 batman
film starring michael keaton the second
movie batman returns was much darker in
tone and more
to tim burton's creative liking
and it
infuriated mcdonald's
because
here was a movie that was kind of
frightening to young children they even
mcdonald's even issued an apology there
are videos on youtube you can look up
about this
mcdonald's actually issued an apology
when they released a series of penguin
catwoman and batman toys because the
movie didn't really fit the young
demographic that would have bought say a
happy meal
so you've got
your your
your budget concerns
your are we going to be able to make
toys
are we going to be able to you know put
the cast in that we want like
in addition to concerns about well
uh this movie costs a lot
is it going to play in other countries
is it going to play to a worldwide
audience because we're spending
400 million dollars on this thing
once you have all of these concerns on
the shoulders of a creator it's very
difficult
it's very difficult to come out the
other end with something that
still has that vibrancy of a single
creative vision now some filmmakers have
learned to work within that system very
well
i would say that uh christopher nolan is
one of the filmmakers that has
had more success than failure in in that
working within that system
although they've been uh you know i
don't know if there was a happy meal
necessarily for the dark knight batman
movie i don't remember actually i should
know that um
but his other films as well in addition
someone like a denis villeneuve with
dune he was able to
balance the studio concerns and have a
vision that was his vision of the novel
uh frank herbert's original novel for
dune
so
it can be done but i do think that it
requires a singular creative visionary
that has the full support of the studio
when they say look um when chris nolan
says we're not going to do inception
toys
maybe listen to chris nolan that like
hey this movie i don't think that toys
are necessarily
gonna work with this
right so
but when i think
once you have
you know signed over the rights to
whatever it is star trek star wars a
lord of the rings and handed it over to
a group of people who never created it
to begin with
then what you've got is you've got that
new creative team now saying
i'm going to do my version of this
when it's something that maybe george
lucas would never have allowed to have
happened
or a gene roddenberry would have said
that doesn't fit the universe where
tolkien would have said no this is not
what would have happened in this
universe they're not there to be the
checks and balances so when you've lost
that primary creative voice and it just
becomes
a piece of ip
you know when it's looked on as
intellectual property and then you've
even got in that mix the concerns of
stockholders now for the company like
well
you know we're just going to do this
because it will appease the stockholders
you have so many concerns it's a miracle
that almost anything worth watching
comes out of a studio these days
uh so
i think that's where they go wrong is
you've lost the original person who is
the shepherd for the franchise whether
they're actually directly doing the
writing or not right
so you've when you've lost that shepherd
and it goes to a corporation i don't
think a corporation is
the best fit
for
the
most positive result
it can happen and it does happen there
are glimpses
but for the most part i think the era
that era is gone
i don't think we'll ever see like a
george lucas or gene roddenberry or
someone like that ever again the hoops
that you have to jump through the
concerns that you have to balance
stockholders toys budget this
you know
it's it's amazing i think that's a skill
unto itself now i would love to hear
and i've had very frank and honest
discussions with friends of mine in the
indie film world who all say you know
it's almost like a lot of these movies
the story behind the scenes of making
the movie turns out better that's a more
interesting story than the movie because
the fact that okay we got the financing
but
the girlfriend of the main investor
who's putting in 10 million dollars she
needs to be the lead and she's not that
great
and
so you're juggling i can even i can
almost tell when i see a small indie
mover i'm like oh these are the
compromises that person had to make
because these are the weakest parts of
the movie
and the filmmaker is just fingers
crossed hoping you don't notice
so
um it's almost as if
i i think a lot of filmmakers
would benefit from you know
taking some courses in therapy
in
diplomacy
and
in finance
in addition to being
decent at making films in order to be
able to set those concerns aside and and
make something creatively fulfilling and
worthwhile with that singular vision but
i see franchises you know going off the
rails and i'm like
it's just too many cooks
it's
it's corporate content too many cooks
made by you know committee
and you you can just see it
you know this recent um teaser
for the lord of the rings
the rings of power just came out
and there's a 56 second
trailer for it and i'm looking at it and
to me
it looks like a powerpoint presentation
that was shown to amazon to sell the
series
i don't know what connection it has to
lord of the rings to me it looks like
dollar store game of thrones i it
doesn't have the feeling of the lord of
the rings it's a miracle that peter
jackson
was able to make lord of the rings with
um with his own creative vision but
being incredibly respectful of the
source material and that's a thing that
i think is not spoken about enough the
respect for the source material and i
know that peter jackson he's even spoken
about this you can look up interviews
with peter jackson he said you know i
have my own personal ideas but these
aren't my ideas this is tolkien's story
i'm going to tell his story and this
will be
you know his own vision of that and i
think that uh
i actually think that
part of the reason that peter jackson's
original three lord of the rings trilogy
turned out so well
was because he made it in new zealand
far away from the distractions
of
that could have consumed him
from
you know the corporate overlords in in
in hollywood so
so
being off making those movies
uh
away from that distraction in in new
zealand i think actually helped quite a
bit
we have this quote here we actually have
two quotes i don't know if you want to
turn around i know we said you weren't
allowed to look at it at first and now
we have the big reveal and uh i'm
assuming you probably know these quotes
maybe you don't but if you want to read
them for our audience i would like to
yes okay great
we made a promise to ourselves at the
beginning of the process that we weren't
going to put any of our own politics our
own messages or our own themes into
these movies in a way we were trying to
make these films for him the author not
for ourselves well that's peter jackson
and he's talking about j.r.r tolkien
and this was
his idea
when they began to work on the lord of
the rings trilogy and
arguably the lord of the rings trilogy
of movies is the most successful
one of the most successful trilogies in
all of movie history
and i say this for a couple reasons one
we don't talk about it very often
and i mean that in a good way meaning
we're not trying to wrestle with its
failure we're not saying well the third
movie didn't land
uh you could say that for christopher
nolan's dark knight trilogy you could
say that you could even say that for the
original trilogy for some the the return
of the jedi did not completely work um
so many trilogies or film franchises
you know this is i think where the term
stick the landing came from
and
you know
peter jackson was able to do that and i
think it was because he stuck with this
philosophy from the beginning he trusted
in the story he trusted in the source
material
he had the utmost respect for it and yes
he made changes to make it
to make it translatable to the screen in
a way that would appeal to people who
are not fans of the source material of
the original books of which i am one
i've never read the books not to say
that i wouldn't be a fan if i would read
them but um
sword and sandal uh wizardry that kind
of it's not my personal favorite thing
i'm i'm more of a science fiction buff
when it comes to genre material that i
like so the fact that
i'm a fan of the lord of the rings films
because of
how successfully it was pulled off i
think that's saying something
and i think it comes from the
it really comes from that first trailer
the first trailer for the first lord of
the rings film when you go back and
watch the preceding trailers
really got you engaged in frodo's story
and gave you a glimpse into what this
journey would be like and what the
stakes were and also
the music music's amazing but if you
watch that
the original trailers for the original
the very first lord of the rings film
the fellowship of the ring um
it's i mean it gives me chills just even
thinking about it conversely
with um the amazon series
which is being made
for money
which you could argue all movies are you
know all movies are made for money but i
think when
when also it's coming from a a need to
creatively express something i think
that that's much more powerful and and
when you compare the original trailer
for the first lord of the rings movie
with this current upcoming lord of the
rings series the rings of power
it just seems like
no comparison to me
that trailer looks like
dollar store game of thrones it looks
fairly generic
you know there are other criticisms
about the
you know the look of it not being
you know faithful to the source material
i can't speak to that because i've never
read those books
i just love a great story
i
it's not present yes it's a teaser
trailer so let's cut it some slack i am
hoping
that even though this quote is from
peter jackson
that the makers of the new
lord of the rings series would keep
some
philosophy like that in mind in fact
that's actually a very good guide for
any person
who is embarking on the journey of
making
a franchise
project for which they did not create
that franchise
that's a good that's a good mission
statement
we have a second quote
no let's read the sentence let's let's
okay
uh it felt only natural to us that an
adaptation of the author's work would
reflect what the world actually looks
like
uh
i believe i don't know who said that but
i believe that
is from the makers of the new lord of
the rings the rings of power
and my concern about that is
that
it's they're already giving themselves
an out to stray from the original source
material
uh
tolkien made a world that looked like
well the world he created i don't
understand why you would stray from that
i i can get
you know what their corporate reasons
are
but i think more
a more compelling reason would be the
creative reasons for that it it to me
that statement
that that quote
is an excuse to to
turn it into something that
i mean what are they going to do the
concerns of what are they new they're
going to put hip-hop music in there
because hip-hop is very popular is that
what they're going to be doing at the at
the
you know it's whenever they do that i
mean i've noticed it in previous
franchise well this is especially in
particular music is the thing like well
this is the popular music now so let's
have somebody sing a rap song in a star
trek movie okay those things always
they never work
and what it does is it dates it
and what i what i what i think that
where it tends to work better is sort of
a timelessness to the storytelling
yeah so
that that second quote
uh
is is
really troubling to me
it's it's corporate speak for we're
gonna do whatever the hell we want and
uh
damn your allegiance or love of this
franchise because we're just gonna do
what we think is right and i i don't
agree with that
speaking of tolkien and like old books i
was watching a
quick trailer on a woman who runs an old
bookstore and and about collectibles and
she said basically when we get these old
books we need to take very good care of
them and we need to know we're just kind
of keeping them for future generations
because when we pass on someone else
will be getting this book and we're sort
of like keepers
of the book do you feel like
in some sense it's the same thing with
the storytelling like we're really just
here for future generations making sure
that it's preserved well
i love that sentiment and i hope it
holds but i think we're living at a time
now where
uh
everything creative is being
undone and remade
and not with the interests of preserving
the original author's intention
whatever era that person came from
so
i love that because i am someone who
still goes to used bookstores so i i i
love that sentiment
i have concerns that that the same
respect is not being paid
by
the corporations that purchase these
franchises
for the purposes of updating them
and
you know
adding things that
that just don't work that just they just
stand out and they just
like it's like oh they're doing an
update well
that's over
i mean you see it in desperation there
are certain sort of tropes of things
that would happen i mean they call it in
television they call it jumping the
shark right
in the happy days television show when
they did like this two-parter where
fonzie
is something you would never see fonzies
he's water skiing and you see a shark
and he literally
jumps
over this incline over the shark
he jumps the shark this is now happening
in in movies right it happens a lot in
you always knew a franchise was over
when they would bring in a cute
character
in older television shows they bring in
some cute younger character because some
of the child actors had already aged up
it's the cousin oliver syndrome look
that up brady bunch it's a reference i'm
dating myself but like and and they even
made a joke about it in the simpsons
um with itchy and scratchy they brought
in a character called pucci
which was a skateboard riding
you know backwards baseball cap
uh animal character that wrapped and
poochie was meant to appeal to the kids
and that is a very simplified version of
exactly what we're discussing right now
it's when you're updating it to a modern
audience
um you're
you're
you run the risk of you know one
creatively it's not gonna it's not gonna
work and secondly you are going to
alienate the audience that has lived
with these stories
for decades and
probably read it when they were younger
and have visions in their mind that are
better than a movie that you could ever
make
so
ah
that that quote is very troubling to me
the latter one yes that last quote is
very troubling to me
without checking your phone can you name
all of the christmas films you can think
of oh wow well there's a lot there's so
many that i love it's a wonderful life
a christmas story
bad santa
uh
god they're i mean the i don't know if
you consider the grinch still christmas
it's not a christmas movie per se
uh but i always associate that with
christmas along with the peanuts
christmas special
i mean
oh god there's a bunch
those are just like off the top of my
head my personal favorites the ones that
i make sure to watch every year
and then there's ones that people would
argue aren't necessarily christmas
movies like die hard but i would put
that in that category just because i
love the whole
i think it's become an ugly christmas
sweater that says ho ho ho now i have a
gun
i've seen people wear that costume
so you would consider die hard a
christmas movie for me it is for me die
hard is a christmas movie
yeah what needs to happen in a christmas
film does christmas need to be saved
uh
yeah it's
i wonder if you could even make an
earnest christmas movie now
that isn't relegated to the hallmark
channel and by that i mean a wide
release christmas movie
that that goes to theaters that would
appeal to people who don't
care about christmas it's just a
heart-warming movie that takes place
over the holidays
i think that the thing that needs to to
happen in a christmas movie one it's
gotta take place during christmas
which batman returns by tim burton does
it takes place during christmas
um
it also somehow the message of christmas
has to be
in there
woven in some way
a realization a love of fellow your
fellow man
and and i think that has to be a big
part of it and lessons have to be
learned
right i think that's part of christmas
is this for me there's a feeling
that exists around christmas that is
palpable
and it usually starts around
you know
christmas eve night that you could just
feel and christmas is the next day and
it's sort of a um
it's it's sort of a reconfirmation
of
your relationships
of people close to you and your family
or your significant other
uh and and a way to reach out to family
and friends and
you know
say hey i care about you so that has to
be a big a big part of it even if it's
woven in in the most
simple way
yes i know that it's a wonderful life is
it's dated but i feel like
what's sad to me is that
certain people would think that the
message of
it's a wonderful life is dated
that is where i have concerns because
i feel
that
and in particular this comes with acts
of heroism whether it is in an actual
superhero movie or acts of
self-sacrifice or acts of
kindness towards a fellow human for no
reason whatsoever
whatsoever other than to do that and i
feel like that as a value has been lost
and i notice it in
modern
films and television i feel like
that
kindness towards your fellow
person
human
american you know
neighbor it's it's not as present as it
used to be
unfortunately
um
although i will say if you spent some
time on social media and you get up and
walk outside your house and normally
that that feeling isn't present but but
christmas is is uh first of all i love
those christmas movies
you know but the peanuts christmas
special would never be made today
in
specifically because of the quotes from
the bible
and there was even controversy
controversy at the time about like is
this going to be a religious special
and
it was and now it's it's something that
has survived till today but
i think it'd be incredibly difficult
outside of a
small release
religious
uh you know show film showing at
churches and whatnot or something for
the hallmark hallmark channel you
wouldn't see those kinds of religious
ideals even if it was simply the ideas
without the
bible verses
i don't think you would see that
and it's
you know it's again it's another
fracturing of our audience right like
there's a huge audience
that would love to see a movie about
christmas even if it's only peripherally
about christmas
right but
yeah yeah i i think it is is uh
those values those rituals are
[Music]
they're eroding and they're not as
popular on a mass scale as they used to
be
i i'm just saying what i have observed
but try to get a christmas special with
religious themes
that doesn't
on a mainstream level it'll never happen
enough something made by a major
corporation is not going to do it it's
going to be relocated to a
you know what they call a vertical which
is a small audience
so there you are
when would you typically play a
christmas movie
well uh
christmas is my second favorite holiday
honestly my first my favorite holiday is
halloween
the decorations go up in late september
it's a month-long
celebration
it's horror movies for the entire month
and so i love halloween uh you know
christmas i sort of like once i've
once i'm into the turkey around
thanksgiving uh then the christmas
movies go into rotation
you know and then it's like the the ones
like um
which actually still has some heartfelt
messages bad santa you would not think
this
and you will never look at a
pickle the same way
but bad santa kinda
uh is also one of my one of my
christmas holiday favorites
if you were to write a christmas film
would you be the protagonist would you
see yourself in the protagonist
well
if i wrote a christmas movie i would i
would not be the protagonist of that
movie i would
but i'd like to see if
hollywood could make a you know
a new
a new
christmas movie
you know to me one of my all-time
favorites is a christmas story
now could you make that movie today
could you make a movie or a kid
little ralphie
just wants
a gun for christmas
you know today's climate
it's a little different
you know
i i would love to see and i've heard
rumors that peter billingsley is going
to do an update of a christmas story
i'd love to see a sequel to that movie
with his character all grown up
you know maybe he wants a different type
of gun for christmas who knows uh but
you know
that movie is not just about
christmas it's also a reflection of this
of that this bygone era
and i i just wonder if hollywood is
capable of making a movie about
christmas i feel
and this is not so much a reflection of
the industry i think audiences would
want it
i think that there's so much cynicism
in the entertainment world and christmas
is about loving your fellow
loving your neighbor
and and unity
that i wonder if hollywood is even
capable of making that type of film i
really wonder that so look do i want to
see the sequel to a christmas story
starring
peter billingsley
as a grown-up version of himself maybe
it's set in the 60s i would love to see
that
uh
is that gonna happen i don't know
is it gonna happen to a satisfying
degree we'll see
maybe he wants a glue gun maybe he's a
crafter i
yeah well we'll see but you know i don't
need several glue guns oh good okay so
so someone who makes props and sets and
things but not everybody celebrates
christmas that's true so so it does
alienate
many people
right
different you know what and in whatever
it might just be non-religious and maybe
they don't believe in
consumerism and things like that there
could be a whole anti-corporate angle to
it
yeah i mean black friday yeah i mean
there have been yeah there have been
movies that have explored the over
commercialization of christmas
that's fine i think that's part of it i
think that's a valid critique of the
holiday
and having said that i love the
decorations i love the excuse to get
together
with
friends and family i love the idea of
we're going to take stock in inventory
of the last year and commit to being say
a better person in the new year maybe
there have been lessons learned
and
it's that that holiday period where we
can kind of take a step back and assess
you know
what have you what have we accomplished
what are we capable of doing how can we
do better and and how can we contribute
to a better world i think that that
that
idea that message defies the holiday
forget the holiday forget the
commercialization that idea of
self-reflection
that i think is just important
for anybody you know no matter whether
you like celebrate the holiday or like
it or hate it it doesn't matter
that idea is something i think that we
need to do on an annual basis
when you think about villains what are
the characters who come to mind well i
would say the greatest villain in movie
history is darth vader
that that would be a great villain that
comes to mind uh hans gruber
in die hard i think is is also an
incredible villain
i mean
here's what's interesting the villains
tend to always be
more interesting
than the the protagonist than the hero
why
i i i think the reason that villains
are
much more interesting and much more
popular
than the heroes is
and i'm sorry to say this i think
they're relatable
because they speak to a darker
version
of ourselves that exists in all of us
that we resist
and the villain is caught up in a
you know in at least not necessarily the
villain but but as an audience member
we're caught up in the like oh well you
know i'd never do that but i guess
darth vader would
do this thing that i would never do
right and it's it's always a
a battle internally over morality and i
think what makes villains interesting
especially really
well-crafted villains
is that they don't think what they're
doing is wrong
from their perspective from the
villain's point of view
they're
right i mean there's a reason that
you know there is the term thanos was
right
right like
thanos's mission
was to set the galaxy right
and
wipe out half of all life in the galaxy
so that other life could thrive uh
there's a lot of logic that
doesn't work quite work in the marvel
avengers series you know that that
thanos ended up being the the main
villain of but
people kind of look at that and say well
he has a point
you know he has a point about you know
wasting resources
of you know
so
that's where that term thanos was right
came from
and he is
you know at least in the movie infinity
war
he's such a big part of that film it
really is his journey through parts of
the marvel universe
right experiencing all of these heroes
that you know we've come to see through
their own individual movies and in uh
infinity war
you're you're on thanos's journey he's
the lead character of infinity war
he's the one that is influencing all of
the events
and what's interesting is when you look
at the screen time for villains this is
what this is what's amazing is you can
see a movie that has a great movie
villain like a star wars whether it's
you know the original series or anakin
skywalker and in the prequels
and what's interesting is how much
impact a great movie villain will have
with so little screen time
very little screen time
but the villain influences
all of the other characters in the movie
because the protagonist is constantly
having to react to
some
something
that the main villain is responsible for
always they're the one that's like even
though they may not be present on screen
the villain
the main villain in a story is always
the person that is influencing events
so
and darth vader to me is the culmination
of probably some of the best aspects of
of
villains from all types uh you know
whether it be from you know movie
serials or comic books uh it's
fairly easy to argue that darth vader
was very influenced by dr doom from the
fantastic four comic books created by
stan lee
the look of darth vader kind of based on
that also based on
a little bit of a samurai in there
in terms of the helmet and and other
aspects of darth vader's character and
the fact that it took
you know
uh you know david prowses an actor
uh and then james earl jones as a voice
actor to kind of create this and also
the physical look you know the costume
designers and and whatnot and and ralph
bakshi to kind of design the character
or versions of the character to what it
became on screen so so much went into
the creation of darth vader as a villain
and that darth vader has a tragic
backstory that only a piece of it
becomes revealed in the second movie in
which darth vader appeared the empire
strikes back
you know villains have layers
heroes are pretty much like i want to do
the good thing i'm going to resist doing
the bad thing
okay
villains
there's much more tragedy pain
trauma and i think that that actually
makes them
more relatable
not in the sense that we would want to
act out uh and or emulate any of the
things that a villain on screen would do
in particular say villains from
quentin tarantino movies right they were
the you know main antagonists of those
of those of quentin tarantino's films
but like it's a way to kind of like
exercise your own demons
right like
and that's why i think that movie
villains are so popular and that's why i
think that
i don't even think i need to look at a
poll i'm i'm certain that if you looked
up best movie villains darth vader is
going to be in the number one if not in
the top three position
and and i think that they'll always be a
source of fascination i think i think
that
of late though
it's gotten to the point now where
there's a deconstruction of villains
okay it's like well what led to this
person becoming the villain right with
movies like cruella or even the star
wars prequels right like what led to
this person they started out as good but
then they became bad well what is that
journey like and that's become a whole
other
genre unto itself right the
deconstruction of a movie villain and
showing it from their point of view
and i guess from darth vader's point of
view you know he wanted to set the
galaxy right
and
you know uh
so from darth vader's point of view from
anakin skywalker's point of view he was
doing the right thing
i don't know i and i think that you know
from thanos's point of view the same
thing from other great movie villains
point of views
you know
they had a mission they were trying to
fulfill i just think that um
villains always tend to be the most
interesting characters
are villains always the most unlikable
or is unlikeability and villain two
separate characters
yeah i i
i don't know i unlikeability
is i i don't know it's like an um
unlikable in in the sense of you know
you're gonna like the villain otherwise
the hero has no journey right
uh and and
yeah i think unlikable is
you know maybe a term better used for
like a side character or whatnot or an
unlikable character um
might be better way to describe han solo
in the first star wars movie where he
was kind of uh he was selfish he was out
for himself he only cared about money
didn't care about the cause that the
that uh princess leia was on
and he was you know parts of him were
unlikable he was still it's look it's
harrison ford he's very attractive
man that chiseled jaw sure i'm very
envious of that trigger
be mean to
but he's you know um
he's unlikable and has a redemption
right so that redemption arc is
important not just you know and we've
seen it happen more with villains
i don't think necessarily thanos had a
redemption arc um you know but the story
of darth vader is a redemption arc which
is a very christian story
what about female villains
yeah uh
because if you i'm sorry to interrupt
but walter white's wife in breaking bad
was she really a villain or she just
unlikeable oh that's interesting
uh
yeah i mean i i would i would probably
say
unlikable but
from her
point of view i feel like the audience
can relate to
the you know the moral dilemma that
she's faced with which influences her
decision making so i i don't know that i
would consider her necessarily a villain
but but
you know unlikable in the sense that
walter white is you know
he's our guy he's the it's right you
understand stories about him
and
but i but i feel some empathy for her
from the standpoint of well
she's making the decisions for what she
thinks is best
so while while i would understand with
some understand and empathize with her
decision making wouldn't necessarily
agree with it
was there a villain in amelie
i mean look i think
i i think i think the villain in amelie
was amelie's agoraphobia really and her
um ability to relate to other people
that was the thing that she needed to
overcome
here she is kind of in love with the
world but the shy quiet girl who you
know um
has
uh you know
she she gains
this
you know delight over connecting people
with
with some aspect of them that that
reawakens some love right which begins
with that little box of toys and the
the uh
and and her journey the sort of you know
like she's she's doing good in that
sense but then you know the person she's
thinking about all these other people
and how she can kind of help them along
the way and she's she thinks about
herself last right uh but
but then that journey becomes about her
you know overcoming her own agoraphobia
i don't know if that could be considered
a villain in the movie but it's
certainly the challenge that the
protagonist must overcome and i would
say a mild case of agoraphobia uh in her
case sure
it's not like panic no no no but yeah
but you know she
she repelled from
connecting
with
a
with someone who could be a lover for
her she repelled from it and she
walked away fearful from it she resisted
it
and and then
it comes full force
that's such a great movie amelie is such
a such a
movie that is in a category all its own
that defies
you know
you know
it's such a simple story and yet a
complex one all at once
and it's not a story that is told well
very often
so having seen it in the theater when it
first came out
in that movie is is just incredible
who are some of the smartest villains
you can think of
well
i don't know that i would classify them
as smart
i i actually
like when there's a decent bond villain
but the fact that they keep getting
tripped up by bond
means they're not very good villains
you know it's i mean it's almost it's
almost laughable or comical
um that so many movie villains
i feel like these movie villains should
watch movies with other villains because
then they'd see kind of like the roots
of their mistakes
which is one
the main cause of death of a movie
villain is falling from a high place
so don't be anywhere high like if you're
gonna construct a throne room in a half
constructed death star try not to put it
somewhere where there's a chasm where
you could fall to your death
i'm referencing of course
the return of the jedi and
and the emperor and his untimely demise
or did he die i don't know was never
really explained
in any case
so
yeah i i i don't know i think the
smartest villains are always kind of
several steps ahead
of their protagonist
and
i mean to me the uh
the trio of villains in the original
raiders of the lost ark
i think are i think we're great because
at the end
you know indiana jones did not win
he simply kept his eyes closed when they
when they opened the ark so he was
immune to the dark spirits that were
released from the ark
but bellock and his
you know the the
his
his
cohorts were all taken out by their
carelessness their you know
their their lust for power
right of getting the ark i i feel i feel
that what a lot of people forget about
you know raiders of the lost ark is that
you know indiana jones doesn't win he
fails he fails in the end the villains
win
and then they become a victim
of their of you know
their own hubris they're you know
they're
taken out by
the the deceased spirits
it was never really explained
we had this question come in on our
youtube channel from kp
is the name what can creatives do to
help make the film industry better and
more free for artistic creation how can
we get back to making great movies again
kp first of all that is a great question
how can we get back
to making movies that are great and by
great you i'm going to guess that you
mean just a broad appeal and a
satisfying experience an experience
where you walk out of the theater and
you know wow not only did you enjoy that
experience you wanna you wanna go back
and see the movie several times
i have not had that feeling
very often
i wanna go back and see a movie again
because i wanna
you know
just ride that ride it feels it's almost
like a ride an exhilaration
you know
so
how do we get back to that i think what
we have to do is uh really foster and
mentor talent young talent
not simply
fill a writer's room and there's seven
different writers for a project and
really really mentor
new and up-and-coming talent
and foster that
one
number two and i know that hollywood is
is averse to this but almost everything
you see that's on a large
scale in terms of a big budget
is based on pre-existing material
a comic book that's been around a comic
book property that's been around for 80
years
you know
uh a stage play
that is
you know been on broadway for decades
or a remake
of a cartoon and now this is the live
action version and whatnot so seeking
out something original
something original that that it may have
some source material but hasn't been
made five six seven eight times i know
that's a risk i know that's a risk
but i i think it's important to seek it
out you know san diego comic-con
used to be which is something it's an
event that i've attended
for
longer than i care to remember but
that used to be a place
that development executives from
hollywood would go down
to san diego from los angeles and they
would seek out like
a small
comic book that no one's ever heard of
that has
a an amazing hook an amazing story it
was a place to look for new material
i feel like that
has to come back and in addition i think
it's a more informed
development community so that would be
my my third thing is a development
community that really reads
that isn't just aware of
you know like oh yeah yeah i know star
trek
you know but you know has seen all the
episodes of
every star trek series ever made
right
in including the you know
unaired pilot
right like just has has seen it all so i
think a just more informed
base of people working in hollywood that
that while they're burdened with the
concerns of like well how is this going
to fit marketing
stockholders this just
be aware
of the
you know other creative possibilities
that are out there including original
intellectual property i even hate using
that word ip on intellectual property
but you know there are very few
creatives in hollywood now that are even
given the power to be able to exercise
that christopher nolan is is one of the
people that's that's been able to do
that but there are far few
so and then i think part of it is also
developing talent so
attending your major film festivals and
looking for movies made by
small up-and-coming filmmakers i mean
i've seen it i've seen it in the room
where i've seen like you know a movie
made for ten thousand dollars
shot with just like
you know almost not you know just like
these are the resources we had but you
see the creativity through the adversity
you know there's
not a lot of money there's not but you
see like oh there's a vision there
there's a vision there's a visionary
that's behind that so i think it's
really seeking that out you know it's
it's not much different than
you know
someone going out and
seeking talent for a football team you
know or a professional you know a
professional sports team right you got
to seek out talent and that means you've
got to look at people as they're coming
up through the ranks which is going to
be your film festivals and everyone
who's been in a position
that is now successful whether it's a
james gunn or whether it's a christopher
nolan whether it's a taiko watidi
all of them started in indie film they
all started with small movies taikawa td
had a movie that was at sundance uh
christopher nolan had a movie at both
slam dance and then the following year
sundance with momento his first movie
following was at slam dance
james gunn started with
exploitation movies he worked for lloyd
kaufman at troma pictures
so
these creatives
you know really were able to cut their
teeth
when kind of it didn't matter you know
the stakes were low
you know the budgets were low the stakes
were low they could make mistakes it's
fine it's okay and
then we're able to kind of like okay get
bigger and bigger bigger budgets and
prove themselves certainly you know all
of those filmmakers taika with td james
gunn christopher nolan all of them
you know started with smaller projects
and built along the way
and were able to
make mistakes at a time when it
necessarily
didn't matter but also they had that
they were able to develop that creative
vision
you know especially in particular if you
look at the movie that james gunn made
before he was hired by marvel
to do
guardians of the galaxy
he did a movie called super starring
rayne wilson
and it's a superhero movie
about a guy who's kind of fed up with
the world and just decides he's going to
be a
you know
superhero and he's going to fight crime
it's also a comedy i mean it's very much
it's no different tone wise with a lot
of james gunn's later work but you see
it the seeds of it in super really where
his kind of all came together
and and from that he was able to then do
a big budget marvel superhero movie
where he was given pretty much creative
reign
he put together and james has talked
about this in other interviews you can
look it up he put together like what
they call
a presentation some would call it a look
book it's this is what he wanted the
world to be so he he really laid out
like this is the tone of guardians the
galaxy this is the universe it's the
cosmic marvel universe which is
different than other types of marvel
movies it was you know
the first to kind of delve in that arena
and
you know
when you track the careers of those
creatives who did much smaller work and
move up the scale i think that needs to
be developed more even if it's a matter
of you find a filmmaker at a
you know from a film festival or a
filmmaker that put out a movie on a
small label like a gravitas ventures or
wild eye releasing or october coast
these are the small indie
you know
indie film distributors
that or there's a company called indie
rights these small look at these movies
and you can see
you know there are filmmakers there are
gems
there are diamonds in the rough that
have put out films at all of those
companies that are ready to maybe go to
maybe not necessarily a hundred million
dollars but the next level up and then
see what's possible
and i feel like that type of talent
needs to be
needs
needs to be fostered mentored grown you
know
would memento be successful if it came
out today if we'd never heard of
christopher nolan
i actually think i actually think if
memento came out today it would be
successful it's such an original story
it's so
it's it's
you know one of those things where it
work it's a movie memento is on a short
list of movies that i see require a
second viewing to completely grasp all
of it then you notice it it's like oh
it's story's converging right like it's
it's it's such a fascinating you know
you know twist on a traditional
narrative
right with familiar aspects
things we you know we've seen before
it's like okay it's kind of a noir a
mystery right but there's more to it so
yeah i actually think that that would be
successful but i don't want to talk
about this too much because some stereo
executive is watching this right now
saying we need to remake momento someone
is doing right now there's a studio
executive i see you
i see you studio executive whoever you
are
remake momento yeah sure why not all
right fine
go ahead
but give the opportunity to a young up
up-and-coming filmmaker if you're going
to do that
instead of post-its he'll use notes
who knows yeah so notes on the phone
right you could you could update it but
in a way that's
a way that's clever and interesting not
that compromises the story i re yeah
yeah yeah that's a whole other thing
how can indie filmmakers compete with
hollywood
the way that indie filmmakers can
compete with hollywood is on the level
of ideas
because there are ideas that hollywood
is gutless to explore
you will never be able to compete with
hollywood necessarily on a budget
standpoint
marketing money
having said that there are so many more
things at your disposal as an indie
filmmaker that you didn't realize
whether it comes to talent
and asking someone who would bring money
to a project
who knows who that actor might be
who is like you know you know
maybe sitting around works three months
of the year and the rest of the time is
playing dungeons and dragons
not a joke
there's a whole group of hollywood
actors that play dungeons and dragons
might not be a bad thing to learn but
there are more things at your disposal
than than you would realize so i would
say focus on casting
um focus on making the film because
there's really no excuse for an indie
filmmaker because equipment is so
inexpensive i mean you know
[Music]
i almost look good with the cameras
being used right now but and these
cameras are not particularly expensive
to rent and or purchase
so on that level make sure that you have
that covered but the way indie film
competes with hollywood is with ideas
and then what happens is those ideas
will be ripped off by hollywood
because that's
how that
cycle works now that's fine
if they hire the person
to do that i mean sam raimi arguably if
you look at the evil dead series the
original evil dead film evil dead 2 dead
by dawn and the evil dead 3 that that um
he's basically remaking the same movie
over and over again with a big budget i
don't have a problem with that because
it's sam raimi doing it
let him do it that's great
and and those movies hold up they're
really fun the evil dead films with
bruce campbell
which have amazing commentary tracks if
you can track them down
very useful films from from sam raimi's
early career
but where i think indie film competes is
ideas so here's what you do
don't do what hollywood is doing because
you can't do that
on a budget scale what you can do
is explore ideas that hollywood would
not have the guts to do
that hollywood is constrained by
checklists that they must always have in
a big hollywood movie
indie filmmakers are not burdened by
that checklist
and you have to be fearless when it
comes to how you may be perceived on
social media
right
fearless
stop caring what other people think
move
full force with your creative vision and
that's not something that if you look
work for a major studio and you make a
movie with budget and concerns that i
think comes with burden i mean i've
you've heard the stories time and again
of
of the the burdens that come with
or the the creative shackles that come
with making a movie for a major studio
you
have complete creative freedom and you
need to exercise if you're not
exercising it why are you making it
indie just just pitch it to hollywood
and let them give you the money and move
on but if you're going to make a small
indie movie
you better be willing to explore some
ideas because
it's underestimated
and under used
the audience's imagination
i'll give you an example a throwaway
line from star wars i know star wars
comes up
okay
um
uh grand moff tarkin walks in the room
darth vader walks the room they they're
having a council meeting right on the
death star
and he talks about the emperor has wiped
away the imperial senate they'll not be
a concern for us i'm not quoting it
correct directly but that's the basic
line well one i'm an audience member one
who are all these evil men in this room
right
this
is already scary secondly wait there's
an emperor of the galaxy and there's an
imperial senate who is this emperor of
the galaxy there was an imperial senate
why were they wiped away
and the the thing is is that hollywood
has become so used to the fact that they
can just do anything
why don't we just show that right so we
can show this well ultimately when we
finally saw the imperial centered in the
prequels it was a little maybe
underwhelming like oh okay that's what
it looks like it looks like a lamps plus
uh or you know that's weird
configuration of it looks like a giant
chandelier upside down okay weird um in
any case but what i'm saying is is that
my imagination as a kid
was utilized
because
characters in the movie talked about
off-screen events happening
and i think that that is a
device that is underused
so as a filmmaker i would say to you
use the audience's imagination
you don't necessarily have to show
everything there are different ways for
information to get begotten across and
not just through some news report
right that's the that's the lazy go-to
is a news report on the news you know
they call it
the device they call it captain
narrative where it's like somebody that
just sort of explains the narrative to
kind of catch the audience up with what
events are happening
so
my suggestion is try to use parts of the
audience's brain
that they're not used to using which is
their imagination i think that not only
will you'll engage the audience more get
them to you know whether they physically
do it or metaphorically kind of or they
just sort of lean into the story they're
just sort of
leaning in and and gets them to think
about what the events they're seeing
like oh like
this
and also i think it shows respect for
the audience
right it doesn't mean you're not going
to have
your money shots in the film whether it
be something big budget or whatnot but
you know you can expand your world by
allowing the audience to use their
imagination and convey information in a
shorthand whether it be dialogue
something that's seen very quickly
um
i i i
see that less often
in
major studio movies and i'd like to see
it used more often in independent films
you know explore an idea that's never
been
discussed or explored or explored in a
way that is new and fresh
that's what i think is the power for an
independent filmmaker you
you need to
really
make sure that those ideas are so
compelling that if you just
tell someone the idea
they'll lose their minds it almost
sounds like you're referring again to
the topic of puzzles
right yeah because you know maybe
showing a crime that you you we don't
see the crime that was committed but we
hear about it from different people's
points of view that's that could be one
aspect of making the audience guess
yeah absolutely it it gives the audience
something to do because i mean look
what's the number one thing you want to
do in a movie you want how do you want
the audience to feel you want the
audience to feel that they care about
what's going to happen next what's going
to happen next right and you're leading
them along and you're giving them crumbs
but not all of it right and give them
some work to do
and i feel like they're the reason that
the original star wars films
hold up the original trilogy is because
it gave the audience something to do
there's so much of what's seen in the
original star wars trilogy that's never
explained
you know
that that are such clever throwaway
ideas
that are in the background that just
spur the imagination and that's hardly
done these days i mean if anything
audiences are spoon-fed and
over-explained things are over-explained
to them because
studios think that audiences are stupid
and that's not the case
audiences are much
more savvy these days they're way far
ahead which is why so much content is
like meh it was okay
i can't tell you how many times i've
walked out of a big hollywood movie and
forgotten it by the time i walked in my
car
like a big action movie where you're
like well none of that really mattered
what were the stakes
i didn't it seems like i've seen it
before
i feel like indie film has the freedom
to
go a few layers deeper and explore
new ideas and engage the audience with
it
so
please more of that